حسناء الدومي فتاه قادتها احلامها لتصبح
اول مدربه مغربيه في كره قدم الرجال
ترتفع نسبه المدربين الرجال في عالم كره
القدم النسائيه نظرا لعدم توفر الفرص
للسيدات ليصبحوا مدربات خلال السنوات
الماضيه وفي ظل الاتجاه نحو تمكين المراه
في عالم كره القدم بات هناك العديد من
المدربات اللاتي حصلنا على فرصهن في قياده
الفرق النسويه ولكن في المغرب هناك قصه من
نوع اخر
حسناء الدومي صاحبه ال 29 عاما اصبحت اول
مدربه لفريق كره قدم للرجال في المغرب بعد
توليها تدريب فريق الفقيه بن صالح الذي
ينشد في دوري الدرجه الثانيه لتدخل تاريخ
الرياضه المغربيه وتبدا مشوارها الذي
ستحاول فيه ترك بصمه غير مسبوقه حسناء
سطرت رحلتها مع كره القدم مبكرا حيث بدات
شغفها باللعبه في المدرسه ورفقه جيرانها
قبل ان تلمس في نفسها الموهبه وتقرر السير
في طريق الاحتراف رحلتها كلعيبه محترفه
بدات عام 2008 عبر نادي اطلس 5 واستمرت 10
سنوات وصلت فيها لنهائي كاس العرش مرتين
قبل ان تعتزل في 2018 وتتجه الى التدريب
مشروعها كمدربه بدا قبل الاعتزال حيث حصلت
في 2014 على دوره تدريبيه بمعهد مولاي
رشيد قبل ان تحصد رخصه الاتحاد الافريقي
لكره القدم كاف عام 2018 كاول سيده مغربيه
تحقق ذلك وفي 2022 تلقى الدعوه الرسميه من
الجامعه الملكيه لكره القدم في المغرب
لاجتياز الاختبارات والحصول على شهاده
تدريب معتمده وتلقت حسناء النصيحه بان
تتحول الى التدريب في عالم كره قدم الرجال
حيث اشاد كل من شاهدوا رحلتها بتطور
افكارها والمعرفه التي تمتلكها نجاحها مع
الفئات السنيات المختلفه للذكور وفرق
السيدات جعلها تتخذ تلك الخطوه بالاشراف
على تدريب الفريق الاول لنادي الفقيه بن
صالح وما زالت تحلم بالمزيد من الخطوات
المستقبلا خاصه وانها ما زالت تبلغ من
العمر 29 عاما فقط ورغم ما حققته في زمن
قياسي في عالم التدريب اكدت حسناء انها
عانت من الانتقادات كونها امراه تعمل
كمدربه للرجال في مجتمع محافظ ولكنها نجحت
في التعامل مع تلك الانتقادات من خلال
اثبات نفسها بالتجربه وليس بالرد على
الانتقادات وفي الوقت ذاته اكدت حسناء
انها حصلت على دعم كبير من المحيطين بها
فضلا عن ثقتها بنفسها واحلامها التي سعت
ورائها منذ ان بدات رحلتها مع كره القدم
تلك الاحلام جعلتها تتمنى ان تدرب منتخب
المغرب الاول وتعمل في اكبر الانديه على
مستوى العالم ومن يدري فرب تصبح احلامها
حقيقه يوما ما فمن كان يصدق ان امراه
مغربيه يمكنها فعل ما فعلته حسناء قبل ان
تصل الى عامها الثلاثين